all right so you guys know I love the
alien stories I love conspiracy stories
I love sci-fi movies and the riot guys
brought me Jeremy Korbel from
extraordinary beliefs calm and they said
this is the guy that you have to talk to
about all this stuff because I'm
babbling on about this stuff constantly
and they said he's gonna come in and
clean up some of this stuff so let's
start by talking about aliens as I said
it's my favorite topics jump right let's
jump right into aliens we're not gonna
mess around right into aliens yeah yeah
okay so we see footage of things all the
time we see footage of UFOs and you know
something in the distance and I die
walking in a forest and all these things
what for you would count as real
evidence if could someone hand you
something that was videotaped or a shot
digitally or something and would that be
enough is there anything that would be
enough to be to qualify as real evidence
you know it's the first question that I
asked a number of people when I started
this journey is you know can you put
something in my hand I very quickly
decided to turn the cameras kind of you
know away from the sky and towards the
individuals who have experienced things
because you learn a lot more so the
evidence for me is is best described or
the most compelling evidence is the
testimony from individuals who are
involved at various levels from
governmental levels to personal
experience levels who have nothing to
gain and everything to lose by telling
me an extraordinary story that is some
of the best evidence rather than if I
personally have an experience and I see
something earth-shattering like did you
see it they're gonna be like at a guy
with the website right but that's cool I
wish I did see some of these like that
these people are seeing and I haven't
I've seen some extraordinary things that
I can't they don't compute I don't know
how to you know where to they go in a
grey basket but I don't definitively
know as you said the word aliens that
these are so what is alien alien is
anything we don't understand yet this
may be a natural phenomenon and what
we're experiencing are kind of
repercussions of that we don't exactly
know right so that's sort of like when
they say an unidentified flying object
that doesn't mean it's from another
world it just means it's an identical at
Terry calls them UAP
unidentified aerial phenomena and that's
to separate even more from the reality
that there are discs there are hard
physical craft that are traveling in our
airspace with impunity and this is
something that's been going on since the
beginning of recorded human history but
the military got really interested in
this obviously in the early 40s so that
is true and that is a fact we have radar
reports air radar ground radar air
visual ground visual we have trained
observers people who have interacted
with these discs I even you know
interviewed a number of people who are
involved in back-engineering programs
but the point is is that that the top of
it is that what this is all about right
is it about discs in the sky I think
it's about a lot more than that so all
right so back to the original question
then if so you're saying that the the
biggest evidence for you would be
someone that really told you that they
experienced it and they have a lot to
lose and nothing to gain but as someone
that believes in science that's sort of
a hard way to quantify this right all
right I mean the best evidence would be
to experience something personally but I
do not have the ability to like you know
bring this into my backyard so can you
give me an example of like someone that
you talked to that told you of an
experience that was so profound that you
thought all right yeah well absolutely
there so remember there's there's people
of high credibility but did they have
the access and so that's the difference
someone in a position who would be able
to know these things that's very
different right so we held my friends
and I held along in 2013 the Citizen
hearing on disclosure and this was where
we had a panel of 40 witnesses including
the Defense Minister of Canada
astronauts that video okay so that was
my friend Ruben Langdon's and my company
that was our event and we had people
testify over a week at the National
Press Club about their involvement in
the cover-up or their direct experiences
with these unknown objects of unknown
origin so for me that was very
compelling to sit for a week and to
listen to the testimony of again
intelligence officials yeah military for
astronauts pilots had a
second-in-command to the FAA John
Callahan hearing these people talk about
their experiences is compelling the
weight becomes heavy
yeah we are there is a there is a
phenomenon we seem to be in a place
where we are being visited by other
intelligences now where they're from
you know another planet another
dimension I have no idea I just know
they don't have you got to give me one
planet or dimension give me something
you know I would be really sad if it was
they were coming from other solar
systems because that would be a much
smaller understanding then I think is
really the truth I I truly believe that
the phenomenon is bigger than that I
don't think these are just craft or
Scouts or probes with occupants or not
coming from other solar systems it
doesn't make sense there's a much bigger
picture when you really look into it
yeah all right well we're gonna do a
bunch more with Jeremy but I think this
was a good jumping-off point so what do
you think are you a believer what would
it take to get you to believe do you
have to see it with your own eyes or
with someone else's evidence work for
you let us know in the comments